- Hi everyone, welcome
to our daily Homeroom.
For those of y'all who are
wondering what this is,
this is something that we
started many months ago.
It was really when all of us had to be
socially distanced around COVID,
but it's really evolved into, you know,
an outlet to having
interesting conversations
and for us to interact with all of y'all.
As we go to the conversation,
I'm very excited about our guest today.
Feel free to ask questions
on Facebook and YouTube
in the message boards.
I have team members who are looking at it
and we will try to surface as
many questions as possible.
But before we begin our conversation,
I will give my standard
announcement reminder to everyone
that Khan Academy is a not-for-profit,
that we exist because of
philanthropic donations
from folks like yourself.
If you're in a position to do so,
please think about donating.
A special shout out to several
corporations that stepped up,
especially as the COVID
crisis was ramping up
in our servers, our traffic
was 250%, 300% of normal,
registrations went through the roof,
we're trying to accelerate
a bunch of programs.
Special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
AT&T, Fastly and Novartis.
But I will remind everyone,
including any corporations
out there listening, that we
continue to run into deficit,
so if you in a position
to help out at any scale,
please think about it.
With that I am super excited
of introducing our guest
who is someone that I've always admired,
and I'd like to believe
have become a good friend
over the last several
years, Francis Ford Coppola.
Francis, thanks so much for joining us.
- My pleasure to join you.
Thank you.
- So a good place,
a good place to start is, you
know, when we scheduled this,
the world was already in
kind of the COVID crisis and,
you know, I'd thought we
were going to talk a lot,
and I think we will talk
a lot about learning,
and especially learning
in times of crisis,
and what is this doing.
But obviously there's been
layered on top of COVID
other things in the world, you know.
We have the protests and around
the killing of George Floyd,
around not just the country, the world.
I would love your view as a
storyteller, as a filmmaker,
as an observer of the human condition,
you know, what's your lens
of what you're seeing now?
And you've also seen a lot
in your lifetime, you know.
Does this have parallels
with other things you've seen
or is this different in certain ways?
- Well I must say, you
know, I was born in 1939,
so to me the big event as I was
growing up, as I was a child
of four and five and
six, was World War II.
So I was born at a time when
the world was going through
one of the most terrible
of all bad things,
which is a world war,
and of course, I was
blessed being in America
and that we were never attacked
as were our fellows all over the world.
So this, I would say that
this present pandemic
is the most serious crisis
that I have personally,
as a more understanding
adult lived through.
and, you know, my perspective
is that, you know,
the human species as always
it's always easy to say,
well, people are selfish
or there's part of them
that's bad and it always has been,
but I don't believe that to be the case.
I believe the story of
humanity, which has been
certainly going on 50,000 years,
recorded history is only
maybe 7,000 years old,
but there have been, the
human species is a late comer
to the family of creatures
that inhabit the earth,
and we have changed quite
a bit over that time.
And usually there is some
tremendous influence,
some innovation or some event that causes
a re-adjustment of what life is like.
It goes way back to
the time of agriculture
when human beings began
to cultivate agriculture
for the first time and suddenly
land became a priority,
so there was landowners,
and then with landowners
there were the people
who worked on the land and
that evolved into feudalism.
In each face phase of human
development there was always
a reason why things changed all the way up
into, say, modern time with
the Industrial Revolution.
It was the learning how
to make force engines,
steam engines and
ultimately mass production,
and that changed everything.
So this idea to say that
human beings are a certain way
for me is not true, it
depends on what is going
to influence, what happens,
and therefore we can imagine a time when
there are other priorities
changed by other things.
Our human ingenuity is
constantly inventing something
that changes the science called economics,
which everyone thinks, "Well,
this is the way it is."
It's not the way it,
is it's ever-changing.
And so I can imagine definitely
even out of this crisis I see change.
I don't hear people talking so much about,
"Oh, I'm worth this much money"
or "I earn that much money."
I hear them talking about,
"Oh, my family is okay,
my family is safe."
So that I think that there
has been some positive things
we're learning from this crisis together.
- Absolutely.
And and what's your sense, you know,
just as an observer in our country
and maybe around the world,
but especially in our
country around, you know,
what's around race issues,
I think we'd like to believe
that there's been progress,
but there's also, you know, it feels like
every now and then we get reminded,
as we've been in the last,
not just last several weeks,
but last several years,
that, you know, the
things are still happening
that we thought only
happened 50 years ago.
Where do you think we
are in that narrative?
- Yeah, I feel that, you
know, we are all immigrants.
There is not an American,
there is not anyone living
on this continent who is not an immigrant,
even the Native Americans came
here maybe 15,000 years ago.
No, there were no human beings in any part
of what we call the New World.
So to refer to them as,
"Oh, they're new here,
"they're not really born here,"
I heard today on television a
lady berating some young lady
of "Where were you from,
well, this isn't your home."
The truth of the matter is,
everyone in America is an immigrant
and the immigrants have been a source
of tremendous benefit beyond calculation.
That's when one of the
things that gives us such
vitality and innovation.
And certainly African
Americans who came here,
it wasn't even their will to come here,
they were brought here.
African Americans are, you
know, I'm an Italian American,
and there are Chinese Americans,
there are African Americans.
And African Americans have
struggled unfairly against
of the prejudices that grew up around them
during 300 years ago.
And when you think about it,
it will take a big effort
to change the four areas
that is troublesome.
One is of course the
criminal justice system,
two is the equal opportunity
for equal education,
three is, of course, the
health care and the ability
to be healthy, and four, in my opinion,
is childcare and nutrition,
because these children
have to have good nutrition
so they can learn and
they can blossom and be
the contributors to our society
that we know is possible.
And you say well to do that,
to really attack those four areas,
criminal justice is an enormous job
and health is an enormous job,
and it's gonna cost a great deal of money.
But that money has been earned,
because the African American contribution
to American culture over
the last three years
has earned trillions of dollars in revenue
from the selling of that
culture which they created.
Jazz, and literature, and
dance, and so many things
that have enriched our country.
Certainly a percentage
of that as a royalty,
is worth spending the needed
money that we have to do
to revolutionize those
areas of criminal justice,
health, education, and
childcare, and nutrition.
The money was earned by
what they contributed
and they're entitled to
that money to be spent
in those areas as a royalty.
- Right, it's a fascinating idea.
Money, as you mentioned,
contributed over, you know,
300 years, many, many generations.
You know one of the things
that I think we like to do
on this Homeroom is for any guest,
'cause we have a lot of
young people watching.
They're at the stage of their life
where they're trying to
figure out what to do,
they have some things that
they're excited about,
some things that they might
be feeling less secure about,
and when they see a Francis Ford Coppola,
who's, I mean I don't
think I'm saying anything
that anyone would disagree
with, a filmmaking legend.
You know they say, well, how did he become
Francis Ford Coppola?
So maybe tell us a little
bit about your own journey,
because I think especially
something like filmmaking,
you know, you can go to film school,
but it doesn't seem as
obvious of a career track,
as, you know, going to
med school or law school.
How did you become that and
what gave you the confidence,
and did you know, how
did you know that you had
some of the creative gifts?
You know, Ernie H.Town from YouTube says,
"Thank you, Mr. Coppola, for
the greatest cinema ever."
And I think a lot of people
would agree with that.
So tell us a little
bit about that journey,
especially when you were young.
- You know, talent is a strange thing.
And there's two kinds
of talent you can have.
There's that god-given
talent that, you know,
that we all know those kids,
they can just draw beautiful pictures
and they could and
there's no effort to them.
Or they can sing, or they can
dance, or they've just been
given the gift.
The other kind of talent that
really you have to work for.
And one of the beauties of
all of these fields is that
even if you didn't get, I did
not get that god-given gift.
I would say the filmmakers
like, well, Steven Spielberg
clearly just has the knack
and that just was given
the talent to do it, plus
a lot of work in addition.
And there were great
directors like William Wyler,
who happened to be the nephew of the owner
of Columbia Pictures and
got the chance to do it,
but he had just a gift.
In my case it was, I saw
a talent all around me,
my father was a talented musician.
But I didn't feel I was
given any special anything,
except that I had enthusiasm,
and I had a good imagination,
and I worked hard, and I
just tried, and I tried,
and I tried to write little
plays when I was a kid,
and I knew they were
awful, but I didn't stop.
So whether you get that
god-given gift or not,
applying yourself, and working hard,
and having a dream that one
day you'll be able to do
the thing you love, it does work.
I have seen actors who
I remember from college
were terrible, but they never
gave up and they kept trying,
and years later they started
to be actually brilliant.
So you can either work your
way to what your dream is
or you get the natural gift,
which sometimes is not
even as good as those of us
who have to just keep working at it.
And certainly that's true of
writing or any creative thing.
So I was a kid who was
extremely good at science
and I knew all, I understood electricity
and I could make little gadgets,
I could make little electric
motors or do things like that.
And I wanted to be a nuclear physicist,
but I had flunked algebra
twice and my father said,
"You can't a nuclear
physicist if you're gonna
flunk algebra," and I say
my mind has difficulty,
unfortunately I looked at the
Khan Academy algebra course,
and at my own pace I was
able to understand it.
I have more of a spatial mind,
so I won the geometry medal in school.
Because my mind thinks as whole pictures,
doesn't think as a linear thing.
So every kid has the things
they're good at naturally
and the things they're less good at,
And the trick is to identify
what you're good at,
and often it's what you love.
So I loved science, I
wanted to be around science
and technology, and unfortunately
I was taken out of school
for reasons of my father's moving around
and I went to about, I
don't know, maybe 20 schools
before college, and I would
always wander as a new student,
I had no friends and I knew no one,
and I wasn't doing well in school.
So I would wander, the
teacher wouldn't even care
if I said, "Oh, I have
to do a special project."
I would always wander to
the theater department,
because they always
needed boys at that time
who would climb up on the
stage and hook up the lights.
And from up there with
the lights I would watch
and, of course, I wanted to
go to the theater department
because that's where the
girls were, you know.
The girls were either in
the theater department
or they were at the bar
on the football team.
Well, I was sure not gonna
meet them playing football,
so I went, they were at least
at the theater department,
and I wanted to meet one if I could,
or even get to know one.
So I was there hanging
the lights of the theater,
and I would see the teachers
directing the actors,
and I thought, "Well, I could do that."
And so that was really the
reason I became a theater major
and ultimately, when I did go to college,
I was a theater student and
that's where I sort of blossomed
because I was doing something
that I really loved,
which was to do plays.
And then from that ultimately
the transition came
and I went to film school.
I could tell that story
if you're interested
in why I chose film school rather than,
I was gonna go to the Yale Drama School
for my master's degree,
but something happened
and I went to film school instead.
- Well now you've, I have to ask you.
Why did you go to, I'm curious,
why did you go to film school?
- I was very poor, I
had absolutely no money,
and just to eat was like a
major, to have a lunch was,
you know, a major thing,
and so I would hang around
where they were building the new theater
because I knew I was gonna get
to do plays in that theater.
And there was a little
theater and there was a sign
that said today only four
o'clock we're showing
Sergei Eisenstein's "Ten
Days That Shook the World,"
which I knew he was a
Russian silent film director
and so I had nothing to
do and I went in there,
and there were maybe four
people in that little theater.
And I saw this silent movie by Eisenstein,
and I couldn't believe my
eyes, you see this this stuff,
and even though there
was no music or anything,
it was just a silent film,
but you could hear it,
you could hear the crowds, you
could hear the machine guns,
you could hear everything
because of the way it was edited.
It was the first time that I
saw what this magical ability
that film has which we call montage,
where you take a shot and put
it together with another shot
and make something magical.
And when I came out of
that theater I said,
"I'm not going to the Yale Drama School.
"I'm gonna be a film
director like Eisenstein."
And I decided to go to
the UCLA Film School
and my whole life was changed.
- And that relates to a
question from YouTube,
UWU says, "How can you know
not to be too ambitious
"with your dreams in life?"
Was there any point
where you were thinking
maybe I'm, you know, filmmaking
isn't a guaranteed job,
how am I going to pay the bills?
Will I even be able to make films?
How did you know you
weren't being too ambitious?
- Yeah, I had no money,
my father was mad at me because
he had at one point sent me
to military school which
I didn't like at all
and I ran away, and he had to pay for it,
even though I had run away.
So he didn't wanna support me in college.
I had no money, I knew no
one in the film business.
I didn't have a family connection.
I did have the blessing
of a creative family.
My father was a great
musician and I had uncles
who were in music, so
I had seen in theater
that kind of stuff.
But, you know, an answer
to that young person,
you can't be too ambitious.
You are given this unique
opportunity to live
and you should have the
most wild wonderful ambition
you can dream of, because
anything is possible.
I'm a good example of that because I was
as poor as you can be.
I remember, I had 25
cents for a breakfast,
I had 40 cents for lunch
and I could sometimes have
for dinner a Kraft
macaroni and cheese dinner,
which in those days cost about 20 cents,
so I was really poor.
And I went to the most
wonderful film school,
which was in the University
of California, UCLA,
which was, you know, I
mean tuition was like $40
a semester or something, which
was a blessing of California
at that time, and there I
was the least possible person
to get even in the movie business.
And part of me dreamed, of course,
that I could do it, but
the other part thought,
well, maybe I can become an
assistant director or something.
'Cause I did have a sort
of technical ability.
So I mean every person alive
is a unique individual,
one of a kind.
If you're listening to this,
there isn't anyone like you.
So the fact that there's no one like you,
do what you love
because that's telling you
what you might be good at.
And anyway even if you're not
as good as it is you wanna be,
you're doing something that
you love doing, that's,
you know, they say if
you do what you love,
you never do a day of work in your life.
And it's true.
You know, I would do what I do.
I don't even know, so most of the time
I don't get paid for what I do.
I basically am doing it
because I would do it
no matter what.
And that's what I think I
would tell young people.
I remember my daughter, Sophia,
when she was a young girl,
she was a very interesting,
little precocious young lady
and she always admired fashion,
and she was a good painter.
And she was going to painting
school studying painting,
and she said to me once,
"Daddy, am I just a dilettante?
"Am I just a girl, I'm
gonna be studying painting,
"but I'll never probably
be really a great painter.
"I like fashion, I like
photography, I like stories.
"What should I do?"
And I said, "Do everything you love!
"Why, because if you do
what you love you're going
"to learn about all the things
"you love and who knows
what you're gonna be.
"In five years you may
decide to be something,
"but if you were doing
the things you love,
"I bet you that they will be useful."
And then four or five years later she made
a little short film.
You can see it on the net
it's called "Like the Star,"
and she was just with
her high school friends.
And you could see when you made that
that she was a born movie
director and all of her interests,
fashion, photography,
storytelling, painting,
all helped her be a film director.
So even if you're not sure what
your profession is gonna be,
still do the things you love
because there is no doubt
that if you do those things,
they will be useful when
it finally is clear to you
what your profession that you wish is.
And then you'll have the
benefit of all of the things
you were interested in.
- That's super powerful.
You know, the question from Facebook here.
Ginny Nicole says, "Did you
have a person in your life
"that helped you believe you
can do anything you want?"
It sounded like Sophia had
you and probably others.
"As a teacher," so Ginny is a teacher,
"as a teacher, I strive to
make sure I tell each student."
So yeah, who in your
own life and, actually,
maybe in other people's lives
have you played that role?
'Cause I know there have been several.
- Well, when I was a very bad student.
I should have defended
myself, because for my father
getting good grades and
doing well in school,
he had come from a neighborhood
in the sort of area
in New York where the boys
either became hoodlums,
or professional musicians,
or doctors and lawyers.
There was a split, so he
hated a hoodlum mentality,
someone who didn't do well in school.
But at the same time he
took me out of school
every six months and I was
always in a different school.
Sometimes even in a far distant
area, like I would be going
to school in New York and
then suddenly I'm going
to junior high school in California.
Well, California and New
York was as different,
more different than any two
places on earth is today.
I remember being ridiculed
in school in New York,
because I was eating an avocado,
because people in New York
had never seen an avocado.
That's how different it was.
So my feeling is that, you know, once,
so I was not in good with my family.
My brother was a brilliant student
and I was a terrible student.
But my mother did something good for me.
My father didn't take me
too seriously when I said,
"Oh, I wanna be a director
and stuff of plays."
But my mother said, "Listen,
if you're interested in being
"a director, I'll give you
enough money that you can go
"to New York."
We lived on the outskirts of New York.
"I'll let you go to a matinee
of a play every week."
And so every Wednesday I
would go in the subway,
or whatever the method where
I was living to the city,
and I would see a Broadway
matinee, you know,
which probably cost $8
that was a lot of money,
but she gave me the money to do that,
and I think, you know,
that was a wonderful thing,
a gift she gave me.
Also in UCLA I met a professor
who was one of the only women
movie directors Hollywood ever had,
her name was, this is
funny, Dorothy Arzner,
and she directed many, many,
many big Hollywood films
with great stars like Katharine
Hepburn and Joan Crawford.
And she was a major Hollywood
director and the only woman
for many years who was, and
she was very encouraging to me.
There was a time, I can
remember one night, I was broke,
I was miserable, I was lonely, you know.
And she came out of the bungalow
that where the film school
was in UCLA, and she said to me, she said,
"You know, you'll make it.
"I've been around a long
time and I know you will."
And she left, and I was ready to quit,
but that word of this one teacher.
I said, "Wow, she was a great
movie director and if she says
"that I'm gonna make it,
God maybe I shouldn't,
I wanted to quit and go
get back to New York,
and maybe see if I could
get a job as a stage manager
or something, but that
little voice of encouragement
helped me a lot.
I think one thing in the second
part of your question, Sal,
is that American film
directors have been very good
about supporting each other
and helping each other.
I mentioned Steven Spielberg,
he has sponsored so many
young directors and made it
possible for them to have
their careers and even I and
my career took a very bright
much younger student whom I had met,
and, you know, wanted to work with,
I thought he was so bright and I said,
"I'm gonna try to help you
get to make your first film."
And that was George Lucas who, of course,
made "Star Wars" and "American Graffiti"
and as you know is a legend.
But he was the skinny 16, about,
gee how old was he when I met him?
Maybe just 20 or so,
and became, you know,
at first this assistant,
but very quickly not an
assistant, more of an associate.
And there have been opportunities
to give a helping hand
or encourage, even the great,
one of the great all-time directors today,
probably the greatest
living working director,
Martin Scorsese, was a kid,
a younger director that
I tried to be helpful to.
I remember I got him the
job to do the film he made
the film he made with Ellen Burstyn,
"Alice Doesn't Live Here Anymore."
So it's part of, it's like being a tree,
and if you're not planting
new young trees around you,
there won't be a forest.
- And what did you see
in a young George Lucas
or Martin Scorsese?
I'm guessing that there were
other, I don't know exactly
where you were in your
career arc, but I'm guessing
by that point you were
starting to get relatively
established or known.
What did you see in them,
probably there were other
people who would love
mentorship from you, what
spark did you see in them
that said, "Yeah, I think they're gonna
turn into something."
- If you scratch a
filmmaker, what comes out is,
no matter how old they are, no matter,
if you scratch the skin a
little, out pours enthusiasm.
To hear George Lucas talk about film,
he would get so excited about,
you know, you take that shot
and you put that together with
that shot and then you get
something that you didn't
imagine could happen.
There's such an outpouring
of love and enthusiasm
for the cinema.
To this day Martin Scorsese
is the best film teacher
I think on earth.
I would recommend very seriously
anyone interested in movies
to get a documentary
series that Martin made,
called "My Italian Voyage,"
which is a multiset, in which he discusses
from the beginning to end,
the Italian cinema and
goes into every director
and what they did.
You come out after seeing that,
A, you know so much about how the cinema
evolved and developed,
but more important, you
just want to make a film.
And that's great, you know,
that's what young filmmaker,
you know, when I was a
young theater student,
I had three heroes that I
just, I mean they were like
untouchables, it was of course Elia Kazan,
it was Marlon Brando
and Tennessee Williams.
And they represented to a
theater student of the '50s,
you know, the ultimate.
And of course, I was
blessed to have been able
to meet each of them.
But it's good to have a hero of someone
who, if you're a writer,
of whose books you
just admire so much or, if it's a dance,
a dancer who inspires you,
or a composer, or whoever
it is, a songwriter,
Carole King, whoever it is you love.
And it's alright to even imitate them,
because you can't imitate
and that's the beauty of it.
In other words you could
try to write a song
like Carole King, but it goes through you
and it comes out different,
and that's what you want.
I remember once reading
a note about Balzac,
the great French writer, and someone said,
"Oh, the young writers
are taking your writing
and they're copying it."
And Balzac said, "Oh I want
them to, I want them to.
"That's why I do it,
because when they take it,
"they make it their own,
"it means I'll live through them forever."
And this idea that oh, of
course, plagiarism is wrong
when you take something someone else wrote
and say you wrote it.
But to be inspired and try to
do something like the person
who inspires you, whether
it's anything music,
film, dance, that's okay,
because you can't just copy it.
In you, you are such a
unique creation yourself
that it'll come out differently
and little by little
you'll start to understand the difference,
and as it becomes clear to
you that becomes your voice,
and you go on and it becomes
more and more beautiful,
and then some young person
will steal from you,
and you want them to.
It's there for them.
- That's super powerful
and you know one thing
that I think it comes through
in even just your narrative
and what you see in others,
but you know the spark, this curiosity,
I don't think probably the
world fully appreciates
just how much you have that in you.
For context, you know, the first time,
well, the last time we
saw each other pre-COVID
you said, "Yeah, I would love to meet,
but you've got to teach me calculus."
(laughs) Tell us a little bit
about your love for learning.
I think you're kind of infectious
when you talk about that.
- Well, that's very
important, because I think
if I could give this
the subject of education
my two cents, be it the teachers,
the wonderful teachers and
less wonderful teachers,
the students, the wonderful students,
the less wonderful students.
What I would say to
them that I have learned
is that the secret to why we wanna learn
is because it's pleasure!
That learning is one of the
greatest pleasures you can have.
And if the students could understand that,
sure there's lots of reason you learn
because then you'll become
more wise and you'll be able to
get a profession or you'll be a doctor,
or you'll make your parents proud,
or you'll be able to
make money, huh, money.
All those things.
The real reason to wanna learn is,
because the more you learn
and learn how to learn,
the more pleasure you get.
And I always had an example,
I think I even have, yeah,
have it here, why is that true?
You know because you
think of human beings,
they were born in the mud, you know,
we suddenly saw, where are we?
What is this, where am I?
Is gonna get, it's cold,
I'm cold, I'm hungry.
I better find something to eat.
So human beings just ran
into a bunch of puzzles
that they didn't know the answers to.
But because we're gifted
with this wonderful
ability to think and
the tradition to think
and ultimately we learned how to think
that we're able to solve the puzzles
and it's a great pleasure
to solve puzzles.
And I always make this, I have it here,
I have this example.
All the kids know this puzzle.
This is the two nails
that, yeah, go like that
and if you have one of these,
you say well how do you get
these two nails apart?
And some kids can just
figure it out immediately
and others don't.
But if someone says,
look, the way to do it
is you line it up, so
that you see how my, yeah.
You line it up so it's like
this and it's pointing up,
and then you go like that.
And hope that this is gonna work.
You go like this, twist it around.
I knew how to do this, wait a second.
My whole point is being,
you line them up like that
and then you twist it around like that.
Sal, I failed.
- This shows a learning process,
we're all on the journey.
- You do it like that and
then you go around like that.
Or is it around like that?
Or no, it's up like that.
The kids are laughing at me
because they know how to do it.
Anyway, you put it up like that.
Then you take one around.
I'm so close!
Anyway it's great pleasure to learn
how to solve this puzzle,
and later I'll do it again.
But the learning how to do anything,
my point is, it's a pleasure.
If I had been able to teach you
how to do this stupid puzzle
I would have been happy, it
would have given me pleasure.
But learning everything is a lot of fun,
and that's the reason
why we we go to school
and we learn is not because
of all this, the sub reasons
that they tell us, it's because
it's a lot of fun to do.
- No, kudos to you Francis,
'cause I think, you know,
in real time on live, I
guess, livestream to try it,
shows a growth mindset,
not a fear of failure.
And I think we all want to go and try to--
- You can't have a fear, you
can't have a fear of failure.
If you have a fear of failure,
you wouldn't do anything.
- That's right.
- And also a failure is
one of the steps of success
because when you learn what not to do,
then you don't do that
again and you skip that.
So that's the equal step towards success.
If you make a movie that's a bad movie,
that doesn't work, that
doesn't uplift the audience
or engross them, then
you think about it a lot,
and you say, "Well,
next time I'm not gonna
"make those mistakes."
Someone tricked this, they
made it so I can't do it.
I know, one of my kids, no doubt.
- They bent the nails
a little bit too much.
You know, I would be
remiss, I'm getting a lot,
there's a lot of questions
from a lot of film buffs here
as you could imagine--
- Okay, I'll try to be less
talkative and I'll try--
- No, no, this is wonderful!
No, this is, and keep
solving the nail puzzle.
You know, I mean there's
a lot of questions about,
I mean people are asking what's
your favorite horror films,
people are asking about some
of the things that, you know,
Gene Ham from Facebook asks,
you know, Michael Corleone
pops the hole in the orange
and sucks the juice out of it,
and it's kind of a metaphor
for how he treats life.
Is that stuff you came up with?
Was it in the script?
Was it something the actor came up with?
I'd love your views on that.
Oh, you got it out, oh, very good!
- You know, the metaphor of
the orange in "The Godfather,"
you know, I basically
saw the oranges around,
I didn't have an idea about
this could be a symbol
of anything, I just say, "Hey,
take the orange," you know.
Or like when I put the cat
in Marlon Brando's hand,
there seemed to be an opportunity
to use what was around and after a while,
then when I edited the movie,
I began to understand that
that the orange said something.
A lot of times when you're
working on something,
you're sort of half in a
trance and you're doing it
because it feels right to you
or it seems to be logical.
Although I do have a rule
when I'm making the film,
I always try to know
what the overall theme is
in one sentence.
Like in "The Godfather"
the theme was succession.
In "Apocalypse Now"
the theme was morality.
So if I know what the big picture is,
when they ask me a lot of
questions of well, you know,
a director just answers questions all day.
Should she be in a dress or in slacks?
Should she have long hair or short hair?
Should she drive a sports car or a sedan?
And you just say off the top of your head,
yeah, long hair, yeah,
a dress, or something.
But when you don't know how to answer it,
then I always say,
"Well, what's the theme?"
And then, for example, the
movie I made "The Conversation,"
they were asking me what
coat he should wear,
and I said, "Well, he's
really not a detective,
"so it shouldn't be like
a Humphrey Bogart coat."
And one of the coats they
showed me was a raincoat
and was transparent, and
I said, well, the theme
of "The Conversation" is privacy,
so let me give him a transparent raincoat.
Sometimes if you don't know the decision,
if you ask yourself what the theme is,
it will suggest what
the decision should be.
So there are lots of
tricks that you can learn.
- That's super powerful, you know, we--
- And my favorite horror film of all time,
oh gee, you know, when
you get to the subject
of favorite films, there's
always people who come up with
oh, my 10 favorite films.
That is so absurd!
You can come up with a
thousand favorite films
because the cinema, which has
only existed for 140 years,
was blessed with the most
wonderful masterpieces,
even in the '30s, when movies were silent,
there were already 10,
20, 30 masterpieces.
So when you ask what is
your favorite horror film,
you could say "Nosferatu" of Murnau,
which was a silent film.
It's a silent version of
a kind of Dracula story,
that's a great one.
Or you could say "Alien,"
that was unbelievably scary and horrible.
What other, there are
probably four or five really.
Or you could talk of Japanese films,
the film of Mizoguchi "Ugetsu."
That's really beautiful.
So cinema is so filled with
a bounty that you can just
enjoy for your whole lifetime,
seeing the great works
that were made and they tend to make you
want to make one too, because it seems
like such a wonderful feel, the cinema,
it's truly one of the,
well, all the arts are.
And I, of course, like
to encourage young people
to consider going in the
arts because their parents
they just say, oh, become an accountant,
or become a lawyer, or become a doctor,
but partly is because their
parents want them to be able
to make a living, and the
truth of the matter is
the arts is a wonderful
way to make a living,
because what they call
today intellectual property,
which is when you make a
book or you make a painting,
and stuff that's very valuable,
because it's such a beautiful thing.
So I think young people
should consider being artists.
It's A, you will love doing it,
B, you will be making other
people happy and giving them
something that will enrich their lives.
And I think it's one of the
great professions to choose.
You know, more and more
as we go into the future,
there's going to be less and less jobs.
This is not necessarily
bad, which it means is that
people are gonna be able
to do more what they love,
rather than the toil part, you
know, the work that you hate.
Machines, and AI, and other
things are gonna do that.
And you say, "What about the money?"
And eventually, you know,
I believe, this is crazy,
but just like today we all pay taxes,
in the future the state will give you,
will pay you the taxes
because you are a citizen
and you're entitled,
because more and more non-living,
what Aristotle called non-living machines,
are gonna be doing the work, the toil.
I shouldn't call it work, work is fun.
- Right, and one last, I mean
that we could talk for hours,
I know we're already over time,
but maybe just a good capstone.
There's a lot of young people watching,
it is around the graduation time.
You know, what advice
would you give to them?
Or another way to think about
it, if you were them today,
what would you want to work
on, what would you wanna know?
- Well, I think this is gonna,
I know it's a tough time
and people are scared about the future.
I see the future, even the
pandemic, as teaching us
some good lessons that we should value,
as to what's really important.
If you ask people today,
what's really important?
It's that my family is okay,
that the people I love are okay,
that my friends are okay,
it's less "Oh, I'm
gonna be a billionaire."
I have a new word, by the
way, better than billionaire.
I call it sufficientaire.
A sufficientaire, having enough
for what you need, you know,
you don't want to just pile
up a lot of excess stuff.
I can't believe that the
so-called 1% that they talk about
that have all those hundreds
of billions of dollars,
I can't believe that
they're any happier than
some really happy person.
You know, thinking you're gonna have money
makes you happy, anticipating
having money makes you happy,
having it is a whole...
Those people are miserable, you know,
because all they're doing is managing,
worrying about losing it and stuff.
That's not happiness.
That's not even a smart thing to do.
The smart thing to do is
have a lot of friends,
have a lot of capability,
being able to do things,
and having the freedom
to be able to do it,
having a great education.
I think that we should
be educating ourselves,
go to school or being
involved in some school thing
for our entire lives.
I do it, I'm am 81 and learning is
my greatest source of pleasure.
I'm reading a book right now
about fungi that, I tell you,
I always take good notes when
I read because I may want
to remember what, I read
so many books, you know,
you forget what you learn,
so I take good notes.
I can barely get through
two paragraphs of this book
without underlining it.
I'm underlining the whole
book 'cause when you talk
about the subject of
fungi which, of course,
I think I forget what that ism is called,
when you study that, it is so amazing.
That is so different than we think
of how these networks
work and how they think.
It is just utterly a
joy to learn something.
Every time at night when I go to bed,
I always read before I fall asleep
and I always learn so much,
and that's my real pleasure
of life is learning.
And I would tell the young person,
you never stop learning,
never stop studying,
always be learning more and more,
not because it's useful, but
because it's pleasurable.
- I love that, and as I consider myself
a very lucky sufficientaire.
So from one sufficientaire to another,
thank you so much, Francis.
We're the sufficientaire
club, which is an honor
because not everyone
has sufficientairness.
- No, no, definitely.
But if more people were
content to be sufficientaires
instead of billionaires,
then we could all be sufficientaires.
And that's the goal.
- Right, right.
That's powerful.
- And we wouldn't lose
all the individuality,
I mean there was still, you know,
like I made a dumb remark at people who,
I didn't actually make the remark,
I was asked at a press conference
if I agreed with something
one of my colleagues
said that Marvel pictures
were sort of not real cinema.
And I said, of course, they're cinema.
Some of them are just made
by wonderful talented people
and the ingenuity they
show, but the problem is,
is what the goal?
And in the economics that
I read there's the idea
that if you make a lot
of money doing things
that are good for humanity,
that's just, that it's good.
Like if you did something
that just gave people
a lot of pleasure or everything,
you're entitled to to be rewarded.
But to make money that
doesn't contribute anything
is despicable, you know.
I said that not about Marvel pictures,
I said it about just
anyone who does anything
that he just makes a lot of
money that doesn't do any good
for anyone except him.
I said that was despicable.
So the headline was, "Coppola
thinks Marvel Pictures
are despicable," which I never said at all
and I don't think it's true.
But, boy, did I have a
hassle with that one, so.
Because sometimes, you
know, it's the headlines
that argue rather than what is said.
Any rate, I still do believe that.
I believe that, you know,
your work if it benefit you,
if you gain some wealth
from it or some privilege,
if you, as I said, my friend George Lucas,
think of how many young
people he made happy
with the "Star Wars" films,
what he gave to them and,
besides, those people usually
when they get a lot of dough then,
like George, he's giving
it all away anyway
for education and stuff,
and as it should be.
So yes, if we were all sufficientairs,
there would be no poverty.
- Well, that's a powerful
statement to end on.
Well thank you so much, Francis.
I hope we can do this again.
I'm pretty confident the entire
community that's watching
would love this to continue
for hours. (laughs)
But thank you so much.
- It's my pleasure and my honor.
And you know, I never spend
any time with students.
I consider myself a student, as you know,
and I never spent time with them
and if I could hear them and stuff,
I'll learned every bit as much from them
as that they could possibly learn from me.
And my respect to you,
what you've invented, Sal, is really
important and wonderful,
helps so many students get through stuff
that they think they can't understand,
and you teach them that
they can understand it.
- Thank you, appreciate that so much.
Maybe we will do some videos
together in the near future.
- Okay.
Ciao.
- Ciao.
Well, thanks everyone for joining us.
You can tell I went way
over because frankly
it was just a fascinating conversation.
And I guess we don't
really have a hard stop.
I hope Francis, I didn't
keep him from something else.
But as you can tell Francis
is the type of person
that you wish you could, you
know, have multiple evenings
chatting about pretty much any topic.
Hopefully you enjoyed that.
Today is Friday already, so.
And I'm actually going to be
on a staycation next week.
You know, people said,
"Where are you going on your vacation?"
I'm like, "Mountain View,"
which is where I live.
(laughs) But so, we won't be having
the livestream next week, but
the week after we'll be back.
So thanks everyone for
joining in and see you then.